madame la Présidente ma question à
laquelle j'associe Stéphane Viry
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
santé et de la prévention et concerne la
situation alarmante de l'hôpital public
avec l'entrée en vigueur de la loi riste
dans quelques jours
l'encadrement des rémunérations des
médecins intérimaires est une intention
louable et même souhaitable mais pas
dans les conditions actuelles qui vont
avoir des conséquences terribles sur
l'organisation de l'offre de soins dans
la région Grand Est 90% des
établissements sont touchés dans les
Vosges la continuité de service est
assurée par le seul recours à l'intérim
dans de nombreuses spécialités l'offre
de soins est en grand danger avec des
fermetures de services à risque vital
fermeture de la maternité d'Épinal avec
plus de 1200 accouchements par an ou
fermeture des urgences de Vittel qui
doivent pourtant fonctionner 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24
81% de la population couverte par le
service des urgences de Vittel 44 000
habitants 150 communes rurales se
trouveraient à plus de 30 minutes et le
site de vitesse dans son ensemble par
effet domino serait menacé c'est
inacceptable en terme de santé publique
et en termes d'économie et cela
confirmerait encore des inégalités
d'accès aux soins d'urgence entre ruraux
et urbains alors Monsieur le Ministre
prendrez-vous la responsabilité d'acter
une telle décision